Archbishop thank you so much for for
talking to us first of all um the
excitement building towards Saturday no
doubt about it it is an extraordinary
day I think if you've not sat through
1953 you'd perhaps not realize what a
central role you play in all of this how
are you feeling a sense of or excitement
Wonder anticipation perhaps what's your
mood going into this
my mood is first of all it's not
principally about me it's about the king
and it's a service it's a Christian
service it's about God
um I'm very conscious of of what a huge
privilege it is to do it and we've been
doing lots of rehearsals since February
and you know it's slowly coming together
you once famously said that you had a
nightmare uh yeah had a crucial moment
you'd forgotten the crown you left it at
Lambeth Palace yes because it's so
intricate are there any small parts that
are keeping you awake at night that that
you'll be glad when it's over no I
um if I have a superpower which most
people including my family would say I
don't it's I can fall asleep at almost
any moment without notice and remain
asleep so no nothing's keeping me awake
um during the day I am spending a lot of
time obviously thinking through what
we're doing and how we're doing it and
working with others it's been
enormously collaborative we've been
working with the palace with the
government with
you know all kinds of different groups
and it's just been
really enjoyable with the Abbey
um lots of laughter lots of fun and very
serious thoughtful work I know you've
been helping the king prepare as well in
your meetings with him do you sense any
any apprehension from him well they're
obviously confidential meetings but I
mean there's nothing he's very easy to
work with he is
really kind he pays great attention
he thinks very deeply about these things
you can see his Christian faith comes
through the whole time
and it's been really fun obviously this
has been your life now for for a long
time but people have a genuine question
about the coronation why do we need it
why do we bother he's already King we
need it legally because he's got to take
certain Oaths which are always taken out
of Coronation going back to 973 of
various forms but the present Lotus set
in
principally set by acts of parliament in
the 1680s and early 1700s
and
but it is also a moment that says
we're going to draw on our tradition
we're going to reflect the countries it
is now and we're going to look forward
with hope and draw people together and
the the point of the coronation why do
we need a coronation we need a
coronation to celebrate all we have been
all we are and all we will be there's
been a lot of coverage about people
being asked to swear allegiance to the
king this idea of no longer a homage
from peers but a homage by the people
you know a wonderful inclusive moment
which is sort of morphed into people
feeling like they're being told what to
do has it all got a little bit Lost in
Translation
oh I think there's a certain amount of
um
excitement about this that isn't really
deserved by it it in church services it
is very very normal that congregations
are asked to respond that's just bog
standard every day you'd find it in all
church services you'll find it in here
or in the chapel at 12 30 today and this
is simply extending the hospitality of
that and in every church service we have
in many services here not everyone
answers
it's a matter of choice
they are not being told to they're being
invited to join in if you want if you
don't want that's fine well the palace
is very well aware isn't it of the
balance between those you think there's
a thousand years of History here don't
tamper with it leave it as it is and
those who think this is archaic it's too
long and not really relevant to me is
that something that you also had to
wrestle with well
we all sat down and said look how
different the country is since 1953 what
do we do to reflect the wonderful
differences and extraordinary breadth of
traditions and
ideas and population that we have in
this age
that wasn't there in 1953. what do we do
to show that and I think people will see
in this service
something where they look at it and
think oh there's someone a bit like me
there's someone a bit like me this
reflects who we are there's going to be
a lot of people in The Abbey who are
invited who nobody accept their local
community knows about but who are the
local community Saints whether they know
it or not and most of them would say oh
no no I just try and help out
um it's inclusive and
I think people will say oh there's so
many good things happening in this
country people when they see it they'll
realize why it reaches out I mean the
first thing that happens is a
one of the young
young people choristers there present
uh say to the king
you're welcome and the King's saying I
come not to be served but to serve and
that's the theme of the service serving
one another not just the king to the
nation but each verse to everyone
and there are many multi-faith elements
out there right from the first
procession the presentation of some of
the coronation regalia words that you
are speaking as well do you have any
concerns that this strips away what is a
very important Christian service no none
whatsoever we've been incredibly careful
about that
to make sure that people are welcomed
uh that this Hospitality
but out of respect for their faith and
respect for the fact the Abbey is a
Christian church and this is a Christian
service a deeply Christian Service uh we
have made sure that there's no
compromise on those two things and there
doesn't need to be we gain a queen of
course as well on Saturday we will see
her both anointed and crowned it has not
always been an easy path for Charles and
Camilla but after 18 years of marriage
should the nation be ready for Queen
Camilla and indeed what can she offer to
the king and the country I think the
nation knows exactly what she can offer
and I'm not going to get into that
argument but I am absolutely thrilled
that she is there to support the king
and to carry out her own calling
beautifully
did you ever think
when you found your own calling that you
would be the person who gave a sermon at
the funeral of a queen and crowned a
king never not for one solitary second I
assumed that I would be a parish priest
and that's what I felt called to be a
privilege right oh there aren't words to
describe the privilege just don't drop
the crown
thank you I'll do me best
[Laughter]
Archbishop thank you very much indeed
thank you thank you very much Anna